and ponder the question
what if
one minute and 45 seconds of opening
logos yes we're still mad no we won't
stop bringing it up and yes we will
still watch every damn second of content
disney puts out star wars episode opens
on stars cliche oh what's the wrong show
my bad you know what the cliche still
stands i've never been in the desert
waiting for an alien invasion before but
if i were i doubt i'd waste the car
battery by leaving the lights on
for the
yes prematurely celebrating every single
shot until one eventually hits its mark
not only makes mockery of yourself darcy
but also of the prestigious american
institution that is the game of peanut
cup after seven episodes i might be
coming around on this animation style
but what i can't get past is the
inconsistent effort that seems to go
into creating the original actor's
likenesses i mean this is a pretty
spot-on animated version of kat dinnings
but jane foster here looks like she was
designed by someone who vaguely
remembers natalie portman from something
they were half watching several years
ago we're too late the invasion has
begun based on what okay two years ago
you saw the same anomaly wipe out a star
but how are you getting alien invasion
from that we find out later that jane
thinks this is humanity's first contact
with aliens so why would she leap to
this instead of randomly occurring space
phenomenon welcoming anyone to vegas i
suppose if there's one place on earth
where a group of aliens can beam down
directly in front of you ominously
threaten your dull life and then pivot
to an upbeat party vibe without question
it's las vegas so the sin as always is
pineapple shirts more than battles won
or lost it's relationships that truly
define a hero it wouldn't be a true what
if episode if some sudden expositional
narration didn't put the hammer down on
the story just as it's starting to build
momentum go on tell me the thing you
could have told me during the opening
credits instead of the exact same master
marveling we've seen a hundred times
before odin sleeping on a penis-shaped
bed remember heimdall will be watching
wait what why is this a surprise to thor
heimdall's entire gig is based around
him being able to hear and see almost
everything in the nine realms well until
the plot needs him to turn a blind sword
anyway whose bright idea was it to keep
the [ __ ] infinity gauntlet down here
with all of the infinity stones already
inside it do you want to get dusted
because this is how you get dusted we
are going to the most backward backwater
planet that not even heimdall pays
attention to that is how this show is
going to explain why heimdall doesn't
notice thor causing havoc on earth thor
is just going to assume that heimdall
isn't paying attention to the most
boring 11 of the 9 realms he's tasked
with watching and you know what the
biggest sin is here he's [ __ ] right
yeah have a drink it never runs out hey
guys uh carl urban pulled out at the
last second should we just cut his
character out nah we're going for a
needless easter egg record so let's
leave him in but make sure he's
completely silent no one will notice
except those pesky youtubers and who
cares what they think
huzzah shouldn't there be more lasers
probing a flying cow imagine being so
whiny that you'd rather see a flying cow
over alien species being beamed in from
a dozen hovering spacecrafts imagine now
slap yourself in the face and be
grateful for what you have damn it
according to my data the first
extraterrestrial to arrive was
him oh shut up the party arrived all at
the same time we all saw it oh yes the
girl loses her mind over a handsome man
flinging his hair around cliche next
you're gonna tell me she abandons her
research to party with the hot man falls
in love instantly and gets petty about
him not calling her immediately
wait that actually happens
me man had like a hundred sins
i expected him to look more like like
what e.t and less like a hottie mcscotty
beach buddy ken old school abercrombie
catalog i could go on i'd really prefer
if you didn't quirky mcflurry comic
reliefy awkward von speaks a lot you can
make first contact with i don't know
that guy he looks like a loser
big talk coming from
man these forced howard the duck easter
eggs are like quack cocaine to some
people not me though i'm nowhere near
that mallard justed also neither jane or
darcy who have never been exposed to
alien life think twice about this wise
quacking duck in a suit
topaz what do i always say i love cake
yes they actually managed to get jeff
goldblum back to play the grand master
and this was the best thing they could
think for him to say did you build this
all by yourself excuse me i happen to be
an astrophysicist with multiple phds so
no i now pronounce you darcy and a duck
anatodiphilia the hangover part thor led
by the main instigator thor of asgard
who's now taken to the skies what
he left did he did he even leave a note
our multiple phd holding genius female
lead goes from a dog admission to save
the world to why doesn't he love me
quicker than steve rogers comes to save
the day in the captain carter episode a
beeper my dad has one he's a podiatrist
wait are you guys calling a podiatrist
yes because in this universe all beepers
lead to podiatry
waffles waffles who wants to have a
waffle picture we say cheese so it looks
like we're smiling not waffles nobody
wants to have the oh face in a picture
tell me is that butt ugly popsicle stick
talking to me
characters pretend to be enemies to
build tension but end up being friends
cliche
you are the absolute best which is why
marvel will continue to put this
character into as many scenes as
possible this particular scene allowed
them to cross off audience wants to see
loki as a frost giant from their list my
brother from another mother man i mean
that i mean ah brothers forever brothers
forever
but why and how why does the show feel
the term to change everything and at the
same time nothing at all wasn't this
alternate universe created precisely
because thor didn't grow up with loki
okay maybe they became friends later in
life but again i ask why and how in case
you confused it with france wait why are
the names of countries printed on top of
the [ __ ] countries themselves what an
oddly specific consequence of thor
growing up as an only child this one's
for fury
captain marvel eventually moves this
battle out to the sticks but regardless
she still decided to start this
super-powered fight with a literal god
in the middle of a densely populated
area as if to guarantee maximum
collateral damage still learning those
man of steel lessons nearly a decade
later i see
smooth move bro
amarang get it yes we get it and i will
thank you to leave the grown-worthy
portmanteaus to the professional bro
thor body foul says the man who did the
exact same thing to her only moments
earlier oh yes the same versus same
battle where every blow means nothing
and the tension is as dull as a butter
knife yay oh top gun
your maverick is your ego writing checks
that your skills can't cash the ability
to quote pop culture references does not
make you intelligent i mean funny who
are you darcy big fan how can she be a
big fan of someone she's never heard of
for all she knows this is still saheld's
on-call podiatrist
why do you insist on crushing my mellow
loosen up have fun smile a little thor
survives this ready to fire on your
command fire in five apparently it's
nearly impossible to have a finale to
any kind of action-adventure story
without deploying the [ __ ] countdown
to destruction that is inevitably beaten
in the nick of time this time it feels
especially egregious considering we have
no idea why maria is choosing to launch
the nuclear strike early and we also
have no cause to believe that said
nuclear launch will actually have any
deleterious effect on either the
attendant target or the innocent
friendly combatant stand down we're done
here we never get to fire the nukes
allowing one of your characters to
lament the fact that they are unable to
deploy environment devastating skin
melting civilization ending weapons for
the sake of a punchline my suggestion
start in the corners clean your way out
work if you start in the corners how are
you supposed to go outward aren't the
corners the most outwardly point in most
rooms honestly thor i think you're
better off without her help though
oh hello mother welcome to our study
group oh heimdall gets an almighty
asgardian ass whooping when odin wakes
up not only did he entirely miss half of
the mcu congregating on one planet for
the party of the millennia he also set
the bifrost velocity to plot convenience
so that frigga's transit to earth would
take the exact amount of time that thor
required to clean up the entire planet
and put together a complete [ __ ]
syllabus to prove he was studying the
whole time you called my mother on me
that wasn't the cool thing to do jane's
intention wasn't to rat him out it was
the worn figure that her son's life
could be in danger knowing that she
would likely be able to intervene in
some way but i suppose we'll just gloss
over that for the sake of establishing
this romance that essentially puts this
universe back to square one as if
nothing happened and then oh dear
perhaps i spoke too soon wait what
as king of asgard but you're not king
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
guess who's coming to dinner once upon a
time in a far away land
a young prince lived in a shining castle
although he had everything his heart
desired
the prince was spoiled
hollywood movies did not prepare me for
this shouldn't there be more lasers
probing why does everyone always assume
that what am i doing am i harvesting
farts how much can i learn from an ass
describe what marcellus wallace looks
like what say what again say what again
i dare you i double dare you motherfu
yeah yeah but your scientists were so
preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think if they
should i'll chase him around the moons
of nivea and round the antares maelstrom
and round perditions flames before i
give him up
hi everybody
[Applause]